- أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم المعلومات
والحوسبة الكمية.
اسمي John Watrous وأنا
المدير التقني لقسم التعليم في IBM Quantum.
هذا هو الدرس السادس في السلسلة وهو الدرس الثاني في
الوحدة الثانية من السلسلة، والتي تتناول الخوارزميات الكمية.
في الدرس السابق، ناقشنا نموذج الاستعلام
للحوسبة، ورأينا أنه في هذا النموذج، الخوارزميات الكمية يمكن أن
توفر ميزة ملفتة
على الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية، بما في ذلك ميزة أُسّية في حالة مسألة Simon.
لكن للأسف، نموذج الاستعلام
ليس له فعلياً أي صلة عملية مباشرة أو فورية.
مفهوم الصندوق الأسود هو تجريد مفيد
جداً كما اتضح، لكن لدينا بعض العمل لنقوم به
إذا أردنا أن نطبّق
الأفكار التي اكتسبناها
من نموذج الاستعلام على إطار حوسبي أكثر معيارية حيث تُعطى المدخلات كسلاسل من البتات
بدلاً من أن تكون أوراكل أو صناديق سوداء.
الهدف الرئيسي من هذا الدرس هو تأسيس قاعدة
يمكننا من خلالها القيام بذلك.
إليكم نظرة عامة على الدرس. في معظم الدرس، سنركز
على التكلفة الحسابية،
أو بعبارة أخرى، مدى صعوبة المهام
الحسابية المختلفة وكيف يمكننا قياس تلك الصعوبة.
بشكل تقريبي، هذا يترجم إلى كم من الوقت يجب أن ننتظر
حتى تنتهي العمليات الحسابية وفي النهاية أي
المسائل الحسابية
يمكننا حلها وأيها
خارج نطاق قدراتنا.
سنبدأ بمثالين.
تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل وحساب القاسم المشترك
الأكبر أو GCD اختصاراً.
هذه أمثلة ممتازة جداً لتوضيح المبادئ
الأساسية، وكلاهما أيضاً ذو صلة كبيرة
بخوارزمية Shor، التي سنناقشها في الدرس القادم،
وبالتالي سنحصل فعلياً
على فائدة مضاعفة من هذه الأمثلة.
ثم سنناقش مفهوم التكاليف الحسابية بشكل أعم وكيف يمكننا قياسها.
هناك طرق مختلفة كثيرة
يمكن القيام بذلك من خلالها، لكننا سنركز بشكل
ضيق على كيفية القيام بذلك باستخدام نماذج circuit للحوسبة،
تحديداً الـ Boolean circuits
والـ quantum circuits.
التركيز هنا سيكون على الخوارزميات بدلاً من عتاد
الحاسوب، مثلاً، وسنهتم أكثر
بكيفية تزايد تكاليف تشغيل
خوارزمية ما كلما زاد حجم المسائل المحددة التي تُشغَّل عليها بدلاً
من عدد الثواني،
أو الدقائق، أو الساعات التي تتطلبها
عملية حسابية معينة.
الفكرة التي تحفز وجهة النظر هذه هي أن الخوارزميات لها
أهمية جوهرية.
حتى يومنا هذا، ما زلنا
نشغّل خوارزميات تم تطويرها منذ
زمن بعيد جداً، ومن الطبيعي جداً أنها ستُنشر
على مسائل أكبر وأكبر
باستخدام عتاد أسرع وأكثر موثوقية مع تطور التكنولوجيا.
والطريقة التي تتزايد بها تخبرنا الكثير
عن مدى فائدتها ومدى استمرار فائدتها.
في القسم الأخير من الدرس، سننتقل إلى مهمة بالغة الأهمية، وهي تشغيل العمليات الحسابية الكلاسيكية
على الحواسيب الكمية. السبب في أهمية ذلك ليس لأننا نأمل في استبدال الحواسيب الكلاسيكية
بالحواسيب الكمية،
وهو أمر يبدو مستبعداً للغاية أن يحدث قريباً إن حدث أصلاً، بل لأنه يفتح
إمكانيات مثيرة كثيرة
للخوارزميات الكمية.
تحديداً، بمجرد أن نعرف كيف نشغّل العمليات الحسابية الكلاسيكية
على الحواسيب الكمية، تصبح متاحة للخوارزميات الكمية
كإجراءات فرعية
وبذلك يمكننا فعلياً
الاستفادة من كل ما نعرفه عن الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية في السعي نحو مزايا الحوسبة الكمية.
الحواسيب الكلاسيكية التي لدينا اليوم هي حقاً معجزات تكنولوجية.
إنها سريعة بشكل لا يُصدق، لكنها ليست سريعة لدرجة أنه لا توجد مسألة حسابية
خارج نطاق قدراتها.
بعض المسائل الحسابية
صعبة بطبيعتها لدرجة أنه رغم وجود
خوارزميات لحلها، لا يوجد حاسوب على وجه الأرض اليوم
سريع بما يكفي لتشغيل هذه
الخوارزميات حتى اكتمالها على مدخلات متوسطة الحجم حتى خلال عمر إنسان
أو حتى خلال عمر
الأرض نفسها.
لنشرح أكثر، دعونا نلقي نظرة على
مسألة تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل.
صياغة المسألة بسيطة جداً. المدخل للمسألة هو عدد صحيح N أكبر من أو يساوي اثنين، والمخرج هو
التحليل الأولي لـ N،
وما يعنيه ذلك هو قائمة بعوامل N الأولية مع الأُسُس التي يجب رفع هذه الأعداد الأولية إليها
للحصول على N من خلال
ضربها جميعاً معاً.
بالطبع، يمكننا دائماً ضرب العوامل الأولية معاً بأي ترتيب، لكن بصرف النظر عن الترتيب،
التحليلات الأولية تكون دائماً فريدة لكل اختيار لـ N.
هذه الحقيقة تُسمى المبرهنة
الأساسية في الحساب، وإذا كنت مهتماً
بمعرفة المزيد عنها، فهي شيء يمكنك إيجاده
في بداية
كتب كثيرة عن نظرية الأعداد.
كمثال بسيط جداً، إليكم التحليل الأولي
للعدد 12.
هو اثنان أُس اثنين
في ثلاثة أُس واحد.
ليس من المستغرب أن
الحاسوب يمكنه إخبارك بذلك في لمح البصر ببساطة عبر البحث
التكراري عن العوامل الأولية.
إليكم مثالاً آخر. لن أحاول قراءة هذا العدد.
هو حوالي 3.4 كواتوورديسيليون، وأعترف أنني أجد غريباً أن يكون هناك حتى اسم كهذا،
لكن على أي حال، لديه 46 رقماً عشرياً وهنا يمكنكم رؤية
تحليله الأولي.
الحاسوب أيضاً يمكنه إخبارك بذلك. لقد حللت هذا العدد باستخدام طريقة التحليل المضمنة في مكتبة الرياضيات الرمزية
لـ Python،
واستغرق الأمر بضع ثوانٍ، وهو ليس وقتاً طويلاً بشكل خاص، لكن كان هناك تأخير ملحوظ.
وبالتأكيد طريقة factor N لا تجد هذا التحليل الأولي عبر البحث البسيط عن العوامل الأولية.
في الواقع تستخدم مزيجاً
من خوارزميات مختلفة بما في ذلك واحدة تُسمى
خوارزمية الصف الملون، وهي خوارزمية للتحليل
أكثر تعقيداً من البحث التكراري البسيط
عن العوامل الأولية، ورغم أن ذلك قد يبدو
كعدد كبير جداً،
كمدخل لمسألة حسابية، فهو ليس كبيراً فعلاً على الإطلاق.
هو فقط 46 حرفاً.
إليكم مثالاً آخر. إنه عدد بـ 309 أرقام عشرية.
إذا كتبناه بالتمثيل الثنائي، لديه 1,024 بت ولهذا
يُسمى RSA1024.
التحليل الأولي لهذا العدد غير معروف حالياً.
هذا العدد يأتي من تحدي
التحليل RSA، الذي أدارته مختبرات RSA
من 1991 إلى 2007.
عرضوا جوائز مالية
للتحليلات الأولية لأعداد متنوعة بأحجام
متزايدة، بما في ذلك هذا العدد، والذي كانت قيمة جائزته 100,000 دولار أمريكي،
لكن تلك الجائزة لم تُحصَّل أبداً.
أمان نظام التشفير بالمفتاح العام
RSA يقوم على صعوبة
تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل.
إذا استطعت التحليل، يمكنك
كسر النظام، وبالتالي كان الغرض من التحدي أساساً هو تتبع
أحدث ما توصل إليه مجال التحليل.
الخلاصة هي أن
تحليل هذا العدد يتجاوز قدراتنا الحالية.
على حد علمنا، المسألة
نفسها معقدة جداً بحيث لا تستطيع الحواسيب الكلاسيكية
حلها عملياً.
أكبر عدد من تحدي RSA تم تحليله حتى الآن، بالمناسبة، يحتوي على 250 رقماً عشرياً.
قد يكون من الصعب قليلاً
قراءة هذا على الشاشة، لكن إليكم التحليل
الأولي لـ RSA250.
تم ذلك في 2020 باستخدام خوارزمية تُعرف بالغربال الحقلي العددي، وكان جهداً جماعياً شمل عشرات الآلاف
من الحواسيب حول العالم.
الآن، لنفكر في مسألة
حسابية مختلفة، وهي مسألة حساب القاسم المشترك
الأكبر، أو GCD اختصاراً،
لعددين صحيحين غير سالبين.
إليكم صياغة المسألة. المدخل يتكون من عددين
هذه المرة، N و M،
وسنفترض أنهما
ليسا كلاهما مساويين للصفر.
الهدف هو حساب الـ GCD
لهذين العددين، وهو أكبر عدد صحيح D يقسم كلاً من N و M بالتساوي،
وإذا فكرت في التحليلات
الأولية لـ N و M، ستجد أن الـ GCD هو حاصل ضرب جميع الأعداد الأولية
التي تقسم كلاً من N و M مرفوعة إلى الحد الأدنى من الأُسُس التي تظهر في
التحليلين الأوليين.
إذاً هي مرتبطة بمسألة
تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة، لكنها تبين أنها أسهل بكثير بكثير
على الحواسيب لحلها. يمكننا حساب الـ GCD لأعداد بآلاف الأرقام
في لمح البصر.
من غير المجدي أن أحاول عرض أمثلة على الشاشة لأنه يمكننا ملء
الشاشة بأكملها بالأرقام وسنظل نصف
حالات يسهل حلها من هذه المسألة.
لكن إذا كنت مهتماً، اتبع الرابط في وصف الفيديو إلى صفحة الكتاب لهذا الدرس وستجد خلايا أكواد
لأنواع العمليات الحسابية
التي أتحدث عنها، بما في ذلك عمليات تحسب
الـ GCD لأعداد كبيرة، ويمكنك تجربتها بنفسك.
السؤال هو لماذا يمكن حساب الـ GCD بهذه السهولة؟
والإجابة على هذا السؤال هي أن لدينا خوارزميات
فعالة لحساب الـ GCD.
من بينها خوارزمية Euclid، التي اكتُشفت قبل أكثر من 2,000 عام، لكن هناك أيضاً خوارزميات
GCD فعالة أخرى.
وبالطبع نحن نتحدث عن خوارزميات كلاسيكية هنا، وهذا يقودنا إلى سؤال آخر.
هل يمكن أن تكون هناك خوارزمية
كلاسيكية فعالة لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة
تسمح لنا بتحليل أعداد مثل RSA1024
في لمح البصر؟
والجواب هو نعم. بالتأكيد يمكن أن تكون هناك خوارزمية كلاسيكية
فعالة للتحليل وحالياً لا نعرف أي طريقة
لاستبعاد تلك الإمكانية. كل ما يمكننا قوله هو
أننا لم نجد واحدة بعد.
لجميع خوارزميات التحليل
الكلاسيكية التي نعرفها، ما زلنا أساساً
نبحث عن العوامل
وهذا يضع أعداداً مثل
RSA1024 خارج متناولنا.
خوارزميات GCD الفعالة،
من ناحية أخرى، ببساطة لا تعمل بهذه الطريقة.
إنها لا تبحث عن القاسم
المشترك الأكبر. بل تبنيه فعلياً بإجراء
ميكانيكي تكلفته تقريباً مشابهة لتكلفة
ضرب نفس العددين
معاً، وسأقول المزيد عن هذا لاحقاً في الدرس.
بالطبع، كل هذا يقود
إلى خوارزمية Shor، التي سنراها في الدرس القادم، وهي خوارزمية كمية فعالة
لحساب التحليلات الأولية، لكن لا يزال لدينا بعض الأرضية
التي يجب تغطيتها قبل أن نصل إلى هناك.
بعد ذلك سنتحدث
عن إطار رياضي يمكننا من خلاله قياس التكاليف الحسابية
للخوارزميات المختلفة،
بما في ذلك تلك التي تحدثنا عنها بالفعل.
لأكون واضحاً، سنركز بشكل ضيق جداً على الـ circuits، وهي مجرد جزء صغير
من موضوع أوسع بكثير.
لنبدأ بنظرة عامة جداً على عملية حسابية عادية
من الدرس السابق، أي تحديداً أننا لا نفكر
في مسائل الاستعلام،
بل نفكر في
مسائل حيث المدخل يُعطى صراحةً كسلسلة ثنائية.
كما قلت في الدرس السابق، يمكننا بالطبع السماح
برموز أخرى إذا أردنا، لكن دعونا نبقي الأمور بسيطة ونلتزم بالسلاسل الثنائية
لكل من المدخلات والمخرجات.
العملية الحسابية نفسها يمكن نمذجتها أو وصفها بطرق متنوعة مثل نموذج آلة Turing
للحوسبة،
الـ Boolean circuits، الـ quantum circuits، أو البرامج المكتوبة بلغة
مثل Python أو أي لغة أخرى تختارها.
كما قلت قبل لحظة، سنركز على
الـ circuits، Boolean و quantum.
أولاً، دعونا نقضي وقتاً أكثر قليلاً في الحديث عن المدخلات والمخرجات، التي نفترض أنها سلاسل ثنائية.
باستخدام السلاسل الثنائية، يمكننا ترميز أنواع مختلفة كثيرة من
الكائنات الرياضية، مثل الأعداد، والمتجهات،
والمصفوفات، والرسوم البيانية،
أوصاف الجزيئات، مثلاً، وكذلك قوائم من كل هذه الكائنات وغيرها أيضاً.
كمثال بسيط جداً، إذا أردنا ترميز الأعداد الصحيحة
غير السالبة كسلاسل ثنائية، يمكننا استخدام التمثيل الثنائي.
هنا في هذا الجدول، سترون أول 13 عدداً
صحيحاً غير سالب مع تمثيلاتها الثنائية
أو ترميزاتها.
هنا في العمود الثالث، يمكنكم رؤية طول
كل من هذه الترميزات، وهو ببساطة العدد الإجمالي للبتات التي تحتاجها للترميز،
وإليكم صيغة بسيطة تخبركم بالضبط كم عدد البتات
المطلوبة بشكل عام لأي عدد صحيح غير سالب N.
لاحظوا بشكل خاص أن
طول الترميز عادةً أصغر بكثير
من العدد نفسه.
إنه لوغاريتمي بالنسبة للعدد.
RSA1024 مثلاً، لديه ترميز بطول 1,024، لكن العدد نفسه بالطبع
أكبر بكثير من ذلك.
نظام الترميز هذا يعمل
للأعداد الصحيحة غير السالبة، لكن إذا أردنا التعامل
مع أعداد صحيحة عشوائية، بما فيها السالبة،
يمكننا ببساطة إضافة بت إشارة.
يمكننا أيضاً السماح بأي عدد من الأصفار البادئة في هذه الترميزات إذا أردنا أن تملأ الترميزات
كتلة من البتات أو سجلاً بحجم ثابت
طالما أنه كبير بما يكفي. أحياناً يكون ذلك مريحاً جداً.
هذه ليست الطريقة الوحيدة لترميز الأعداد الصحيحة كسلاسل من البتات.
هناك طرق أخرى يمكنك القيام بذلك بها، لكن هذه طريقة
معيارية إلى حد ما.
لأنواع أخرى من الكائنات التي قد تشكل المدخلات أو المخرجات للمسائل الحسابية
التي نهتم بها، يمكننا ابتكار
أنظمة ترميز أخرى.
مثلاً، فكر في كيفية
ترميز متجه أو رسم بياني كسلسلة ثنائية أو فكر في كيفية ترميز
سلسلتين ثنائيتين في
سلسلة ثنائية واحدة باستخدام فقط الرمزين صفر وواحد بدون مسافة أو أي رمز آخر
للفصل بين السلسلتين. هناك بالتأكيد طرق
للقيام بهذه الأشياء، وفي الواقع لدينا حرية كبيرة
فيما يخص كيفية القيام بذلك بالضبط.
غالباً لن يكون هناك معيار واحد أو طريقة متفق عليها عالمياً لترميز أي شيء نتحدث
عنه كسلسلة ثنائية،
لكن لا بأس، يمكننا ببساطة اختيار واحدة أو ابتكار واحدة جديدة إذا فضلنا ذلك.
من وجهة نظر شكلية بحتة، نفكر في العمليات الحسابية أساساً كتحويلات ميكانيكية على سلاسل من البتات
وتفاصيل أنظمة الترميز
التي نستخدمها مهمة بالتأكيد عند مستوى ما.
لكن مع ذلك، عندما نصمم ونحلل
الخوارزميات، عادةً لا نقلق كثيراً بشأن تفاصيل
أنظمة الترميز.
إذا طلبت من شخصين مختلفين ابتكار طريقة لترميز، لنقل، جزيئات من نوع
معين كسلاسل ثنائية،
قد تتوقع أن يأتيا بطرق مختلفة للقيام بذلك، لكن إذا كانا أشخاصاً معقولين يعرفون ما يفعلون،
يمكنك أيضاً أن تتوقع بشكل معقول أنها ستكون عملية حسابية
بسيطة جداً للترجمة ذهاباً وإياباً بين نظامي الترميز،
وعلى الأرجح تتطلب عملية حسابية
مباشرة جداً ستكون سهلة مقارنةً بالعملية الحسابية الفعلية
التي نهتم بها.
الخلاصة هي أن التفاصيل المتعلقة بأنظمة الترميز التي نستخدمها غالباً ما تكون ثانوية وتركيزنا على
الخوارزميات نفسها.
لن يكون أي من هذا مشكلة في هذا الدرس، بالمناسبة. سنركز بشكل رئيسي على مسائل تتعلق بالأعداد الصحيحة، والتي سنفترض أنها مرمزة بالثنائي،
لكنه شيء يجب أن تكون على علم به.
بشكل عام، لأي نوع من المسائل نتحدث عنها، طول المدخل يشير
إلى عدد البتات التي نحتاجها لترميز المدخل،
ونعتبر طول المدخل هو حجم المثيل لأي مسألة نفكر فيها.
الآن، لنفكر في
العملية الحسابية نفسها، والتي يمثلها المستطيل
الأزرق في هذا الشكل.
الطريقة التي سنقيس بها
تكلفة هذه العملية الحسابية هي حساب عدد العمليات الأولية التي تتطلبها.
بشكل حدسي، العملية الأولية هي عملية تتضمن عدداً صغيراً ثابتاً
من البتات أو الـ qubits
يمكن تنفيذها بسرعة وسهولة مثل حساب AND لبتين،
مثلاً.
على المستوى الرسمي،
هناك طرق مختلفة لتعريف ما هي العملية الأولية، بحسب
النموذج الحوسبي الذي نستخدمه.
مثلاً، يمكن أن تكون العملية الأولية خطوة واحدة من آلة Turing إذا كنا نستخدم ذلك النموذج.
لأغراض هذا الدرس، سنركز على نماذج الـ circuit، كما ذكرت بالفعل، وتحديداً الـ quantum
و Boolean circuits.
عندما نعمل مع الـ circuits، من المعتاد أن نفكر في كل gate كعملية أولية.
لقد رأينا عدة quantum gates مختلفة حتى الآن في السلسلة،
بما في ذلك X و Y و Z gates، و Hadamard gates، و S و T gates،
و controlled NOT gates، و swap gates، و Toffoli gates، و Fredkin gates.
تحدثنا أيضاً عن query gates في سياق نموذج الاستعلام، لكننا لن نعمل ضمن نموذج الاستعلام في هذا الدرس، لذا لن نقلق بشأن
query gates الآن.
رأينا أيضاً أن أي عملية وحدوية على أي عدد من الـ qubits
يمكن اعتبارها gate إذا أردنا ذلك.
لكن لأغراض قياس التكلفة، لن يكون ذلك مفيداً جداً، لذا ما سنفعله هو أننا ببساطة سنختار
مجموعة من الـ gates
وسنعتبر تلك المجموعة هي مجموعة العمليات الأولية لدينا.
أولاً، سنشمل الـ single
qubit unitary gates التي ترونها هنا،
وهي X و Y و Z gates،
و Hadamard gates و S و T gates، بالإضافة إلى معكوساتها
أو المنقولات المترافقة.
لا نحتاج فعلاً كل هذه الـ gates. بمجرد أن يكون لدينا Hadamard و T gates، يمكننا تنفيذ الباقي،
لكن من أجل الراحة فقط، سنشمل جميعها.
سنشمل أيضاً controlled NOT gates، وهذه ستكون الـ gates الوحيدة
متعددة الـ qubit في مجموعتنا.
وأخيراً سنشمل قياسات الأساس المعياري لـ qubit واحد حتى نتمكن فعلاً من الحصول على بعض المعلومات الكلاسيكية
من الـ circuits الخاصة بنا.
إذا ركزنا فقط على الـ unitary gates ونسينا القياسات
للحظة، نحصل على ما يُسمى
مجموعة gate شاملة.
ما يعنيه ذلك هو أن
أي عملية وحدوية على أي عدد من الـ qubits يمكن
إما تنفيذها بدقة
أو بتقريب قريب جداً
بـ quantum circuit مبنية من هذه الـ gates فقط.
بعبارة أخرى، هذه مجموعة
gates جيدة بما يكفي لبناء أي عملية
وحدوية منها.
ليس بالضرورة بدقة تامة، لكن يمكننا الحصول على تقريب
بأي درجة نريدها.
قد يتطلب ذلك الكثير من الـ gates، وليس من الصعب فعلاً الاستنتاج أنه يجب أن يتطلب
الكثير من الـ gates أحياناً،
لكنه مع ذلك ممكن دائماً.
ليس من السهل إثبات أن هذه مجموعة gate شاملة رغم ذلك، ولن نناقش كيف
يتم ذلك في السلسلة،
لكنها حقيقة معروفة جيداً وهناك في الواقع طرق مختلفة
يمكن إثباتها بها.
هناك أيضاً مجموعات gate أخرى تُستخدم أحياناً
بدلاً من هذه، مثل Toffoli gates و Hadamard gates و S gates بالإضافة إلى القياسات،
لكن هذا اختيار معياري إلى حد ما.
إذاً باختصار، هذه هي
العمليات الكمية التي سنعتبرها أولية.
بالنسبة لـ Boolean circuits،
سنعتبر هذه الـ gates الأربعة عمليات
أولية: AND gates، و OR gates، و NOT gates و FANOUT.
FANOUT، بالمناسبة، لا
تُحسب دائماً كـ gate، لكنه سيكون
مهماً لنا أن نفعل ذلك كما سنرى لاحقاً في الدرس.
على غرار ما كان لدينا لمجموعة
الـ quantum gate المعيارية، هذه المجموعة فيها بعض التكرار.
لا تحتاج كلاً من AND و OR. يمكنك إنشاء أي منهما باستخدام الأخرى مع ثلاث NOT gates،
لكن لا ضرر من تضمين كليهما وهو مريح فقط.
كما قد تعرف بالفعل، هذه مجموعة gate شاملة
للحوسبة الحتمية، أي أن أي دالة
من بتات إلى بتات
يمكن تنفيذها بـ Boolean circuit مكونة من gates من هذه المجموعة.
مرة أخرى، تماماً كما كان
لدينا مع الـ quantum circuits، هذا لا يعني أن كل دالة يمكن تنفيذها بكفاءة
بواسطة Boolean circuit،
وفي الواقع معظم الدوال
لا يمكن تنفيذها إلا بـ circuits كبيرة جداً
لسبب بسيط هو أن هناك الكثير والكثير من الدوال
ولا يمكن أن يكون لها جميعاً circuits صغيرة. ببساطة لا توجد
circuits صغيرة كافية للجميع.
الشمولية أسهل
في الإثبات في هذه الحالة مما هي عليه في الحالة الكمية كما اتضح.
فإذا كنت لا تعرف بالفعل
كيف تثبتها، فكّر في الأمر وانظر
إن كنت تستطيع اكتشاف ذلك إذا كنت مهتماً.
الآن بعد أن حددنا الـ gates
التي سنسمح بها وسنعتبرها
عمليات أولية، يمكننا التفكير في كم منها
مطلوب لإجراء
عمليات حسابية مختلفة.
للقيام بذلك، سنستخدم
هذا التعريف لحجم الـ circuit.
هذا التعريف يعمل لكل من
الـ Boolean و quantum circuits وهو بسيط جداً.
حجم الـ circuit هو العدد
الإجمالي لـ gates الموجودة فيها.
مثلاً، إذا عدنا إلى
نفس المثال الذي رأيناه عدة مرات، وهو الـ Boolean circuit لحساب XOR لبتين،
نرى أن حجمها سبعة
لأن هناك سبع gates، اثنتان FANOUT gates، واثنتان NOT gates،
واثنتان AND gates وواحدة OR gate. إذا قررنا عدم حساب
الـ FANOUT gates، وهو شائع، سيكون حجمها خمسة،
لكننا سنحسب الـ FANOUT gates، لذا حجمها سبعة.
حجم الـ circuit
يتوافق مع عدد العمليات الأولية
التي نحتاج لتنفيذها.
فلو نفذنا تلك
العمليات بشكل تسلسلي، فإن الحجم سيخبرنا
بالمدة التي ستستغرقها،
لذا يمكنك التفكير في حجم الـ circuit كتمثيل لزمن التشغيل التسلسلي.
هذه هي الطريقة التي سنقيس
بها التكلفة الحسابية لأغراض هذا الدرس.
هناك خاصية أخرى للـ circuits
يمكن أيضاً اعتبارها مقدار الوقت
المطلوب لتشغيل circuit، وهي عمق الـ circuit.
لنكون دقيقين، العمق
هو أقصى عدد من الـ gates التي نصادفها في أي مسار من سلك الإدخال إلى سلك الإخراج،
وهو يعادل عدد طبقات الـ gates التي نحتاجها
لإنشاء الـ circuit، حيث تشير الطبقة إلى مجموعة من الـ gates
التي يمكن تنفيذها في وقت واحد لأنها لا تشترك
في أي أسلاك.
مثلاً، الـ circuit
من قبل لها عمق أربعة، ويمكننا رؤية ذلك مباشرة من الرسم أن هناك أربع طبقات.
الـ FANOUT gates يمكن
تنفيذها في وقت واحد، والـ NOT gates يمكن
تنفيذها في وقت واحد والـ AND gates يمكن
تنفيذها في وقت واحد أيضاً.
لذا يمكننا التفكير في عمق الـ circuit كتمثيل لزمن التشغيل المتوازي.
عمق الـ circuit هو بالتأكيد مفهوم مثير ومهم وهناك بعض التقنيات
المتقدمة جداً التي يمكن استخدامها لتقليل
العمق المطلوب لبعض العمليات الحسابية، أحياناً بشكل كبير جداً في الواقع، لكنه موضوع متقدم
ولن يكون لدينا الكثير لنقوله عنه في هذه السلسلة.
فمرة أخرى، سنقيس
التكلفة الحسابية من حيث حجم الـ circuit
أو بعبارة أخرى،
عدد العمليات الأولية المطلوبة لإجراء عملية حسابية.
في بداية الدرس، تحدثنا عن مسألة تحليل
الأعداد الصحيحة ورأينا أن الوقت المطلوب لخوارزمية لحل هذه المسألة
يمكن أن يزداد كلما زاد طول المدخلات، وهذا عادةً
هو ما نركز عليه
عندما نحلل الخوارزميات.
أي أننا مهتمون بكيفية تزايد تكاليف تشغيل الخوارزميات كلما أصبحت المدخلات أكبر وأكبر.
بالطبع، هذا النوع من التزايد ليس الشيء الوحيد المهم.
مثلاً، قد نكون ببساطة مهتمين بإيجاد عوامل
RSA1024 وهذا كل شيء.
ففي حالة كهذه، نكون نتحدث عن مثيل
واحد للمسألة حيث لا شيء يتزايد.
لكن عندما نفكر في الخوارزميات، الطريقة التي تتزايد بها تكاليفها
مهمة جداً وتخبرنا الكثير
عن الخوارزميات.
وجهة النظر هذه
متسقة مع فكرة أن الخوارزميات جوهرية، وكما تحدثت من قبل،
مع مرور الوقت وتقدم التكنولوجيا، سيتم نشرها على
مدخلات أكبر وأكبر.
لكن لاحظوا أنه بينما يمكن أن تنمو مدخلات المسائل الحسابية
في الحجم، الـ circuits لا تنمو.
كل circuit لها حجم ثابت.
ولهذا السبب، إذا أردنا وصف خوارزمية
باستخدام الـ circuits، سنحتاج فعلياً إلى عائلة من الـ circuits للقيام بذلك،
وبعائلة من الـ circuits، نعني مجموعة من الـ circuits تكبر أكثر وأكثر حتى نتمكن من استيعاب المدخلات
كلما أصبحت أكبر وأكبر. مثلاً، لنفكر في خوارزمية حتمية كلاسيكية
لمسألة تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة، ربما واحدة تعتمد على القسمة التجريبية، لكن التفاصيل لا تهم فعلاً
لأغراض هذا المثال.
يمكننا من حيث المبدأ
وصف خوارزمية كهذه باستخدام عائلة من Boolean circuits حيث إذا أردنا تحليل عدد
تمثيله الثنائي يحتوي على N بت، نأخذ الـ circuit CN من عائلتنا وندخل العدد
الذي نريد تحليله
في بتات الإدخال لتلك الـ circuit.
أحياناً قد نختار تحديد معاملات هذه الـ circuits
بطرق مختلفة، لذا قد لا يكون دائماً أن الـ circuit رقم N تحتوي على N بتات إدخال،
لكن هذه طريقة نموذجية جداً للقيام بذلك. بطبيعة الحال، كلما
زادت أطوال المدخلات، نتوقع أن تكبر الـ circuits
في هذه العائلة
عاكسةً حقيقة أن تحليل
أعداد من 4 بتات أسهل بكثير من تحليل أعداد من 1,024 بت، مثلاً.
وبذلك، مع وضع ذلك في الاعتبار، نقيس تكلفة مثل هذه
الخوارزمية بدالة تخبرنا بعدد العمليات
الأولية
التي نحتاجها لكل طول مدخل ممكن، ويمكننا فعل ذلك لكل من الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية والكمية.
كمثال، لنفكر في مسألة جمع الأعداد الصحيحة، وهي بالتأكيد أبسط بكثير
من التحليل
أو حتى حساب الـ GCD.
فقط للتبسيط، لنفترض أن كلاً من N و
M أعداد صحيحة غير سالبة وأنهما ممثلان
بسلاسل ثنائية بنفس الطول.
كيف يمكننا بناء Boolean circuits تجمع هذين العددين معاً؟
حسناً، لنبدأ بخوارزمية، الخوارزمية المعيارية للجمع، وهي المقابل بالأساس الثنائي للطريقة
التي أفترض أننا جميعاً تعلمناها لجمع الأعداد معاً بالقلم
والورقة، فنبدأ بالبتات
الأقل أهمية،
نجمعها معاً، وذلك يعطينا البت
الأقل أهمية من النتيجة مع بت حمل
يجب أن نأخذه بالاعتبار
عند الانتقال إلى الموضع التالي. ونستمر بالتقدم عبر البتات، مولدين بتات الإخراج
مع بتات الحمل
حتى نصل إلى النهاية.
هذه الطريقة يمكن
التعبير عنها مباشرة إلى حد كبير بواسطة Boolean circuits.
إحدى طرق التفكير في الأمر هي البدء بـ circuit صغيرة لجمع عددين صحيحين من بت واحد.
ذلك سيعطينا عدداً
بين صفر واثنين، حيث البت الأقل أهمية هو XOR لبتات الإدخال
والبت الأكثر أهمية، أو بت الحمل إذا فضلت، هو AND لبتي الإدخال.
أحياناً نشير إلى circuit تنفذ هاتين
العمليتين معاً بأنها نصف جامع.
هذا يعمل جيداً عندما
يكون هناك بتا إدخال فقط، لكن إذا أردنا جمع أعداد صحيحة بأكثر من بت واحد لكل منها،
سنحتاج للتعامل
مع بتات الحمل بطريقة ما.
ما يمكننا فعله هو سلسلة
نصفي جامع معاً وأخذ OR لبتات الحمل التي ينتجانها لإنشاء ما يُسمى جامعاً كاملاً،
وهو أساساً Boolean circuit لجمع ثلاثة أعداد
من بت واحد معاً.
وبمجرد أن يكون لدينا جامع كامل، يمكننا جمع الأعداد معاً
ببساطة عبر السلسلة، بدءاً من البت الأقل أهمية
إلى البت الأكثر أهمية. نحن أساساً ننفذ خوارزمية الجمع المعيارية باستخدام الجوامع الكاملة للتعامل
مع بتات الحمل.
إذاً ما هي تكلفة هذه العملية الحسابية؟
حسناً، نحتاج سبع gates
أولية لكل XOR gate، مما يعني 10 gates لنصف جامع
وبالتالي 21 gate لجامع كامل، وهو نصفا جامع زائد OR gate واحدة.
فعند النهاية، إذا كانت أعداد الإدخال كلاهما بـ N بت، نحتاج نصف جامع
للبت الأقل أهمية
وجامعاً كاملاً لكل بت أخرى، والنتيجة النهائية هي 21 في N ناقص واحد زائد 10 أو 21N ناقص 11 gate إجمالاً.
إذا قررنا لسبب ما أننا لا نريد
حساب الـ FANOUT gates وأدرجنا الـ XOR
gates في مجموعة الـ gates لدينا، سنحتاج 5N ناقص
ثلاث gates إجمالاً.
من الجيد معرفة عدد الـ gates أو العمليات الأولية المطلوبة بالضبط لإجراء عمليات حسابية مختلفة،
مثل ما رأيناه للتو مع جمع الأعداد الصحيحة.
وبالطبع، إذا أردنا فعلاً تنفيذ هذه العمليات الحسابية، نحتاج لمعرفة هذه التفاصيل.
لكن إذا دخلنا دائماً في هذا القدر من التفصيل، خاصةً لخوارزميات أكثر
تعقيداً، سنُدفن سريعاً جداً في تفاصيل
ذات أهمية ثانوية
في كثير من الحالات.
إحدى طرق تبسيط الأمور الشائعة جداً في
تحليل الخوارزميات هي استخدام ترميز big-O،
الذي يسمح لنا بالتعبير
عن معدلات النمو ومقارنتها بطريقة بسيطة
جداً ومريحة.
وهنا يمكنكم رؤية التعريف الذي يقوم عليه هذا الترميز.
لنفترض أن لدينا
دالتين G و H، يمكننا التفكير فيهما على أنهما تأخذان قيماً صحيحة غير سالبة
للتبسيط،
رغم أن ذلك ليس مطلوباً فعلياً. ربما G و H تمثلان تكاليف عمليات حسابية مختلفة، مثلاً.
نقول حينها أن G هي big-O من H، والتي تُكتب تقليدياً
بعلامة يساوي هكذا.
إذا كانت G من N أصغر من أو تساوي
ثابتاً موجباً C مضروباً في H من N، طالما أن N كبيرة بما يكفي.
فهذا يتعلق بما
يحدث عندما تكبر N.
رسمياً، ما تعنيه "كبيرة بما يكفي" هو أن هناك اختياراً لـ N صفر بحيث تكون المتراجحة صحيحة
كلما كانت N أكبر من أو تساوي N صفر.
المفتاح هنا هو أن هذين
العددين C و N صفر ثابتان.
يمكن أن يكونا أي عددين
كانا، لكن مهما كانا، لا يمكنهما التغير مع نمو N.
إذا لم تكن قد رأيت هذا
النوع من التعريف من قبل، فقد يحتاج بعض الوقت للتعود عليه ويمكنك إيجاد مراجع
ستشرح هذا المفهوم
بتفصيل أكثر بكثير مما
أستطيع في هذا الدرس.
عادةً ما نختار الدالة
H لتكون بسيطة من أجل التعبير عن شيء ما حول سرعة نمو الدالة G.
مثلاً، الدالة التي قيمتها 17 في N تكعيب ناقص 257
في N تربيع زائد
65,537 هي big-O من N تكعيب، ويمكنك مطابقة هذا
المثال مع التعريف
باختيار C و N صفر بشكل مناسب.
مثلاً، إذا أخذنا C تساوي 18، سيكون لدينا أن
التعبير أصغر من أو يساوي فعلاً 18 في N تكعيب
طالما أن N كبيرة بما يكفي.
بربط هذا الترميز بمثال
جمع الأعداد الصحيحة، ما يمكننا قوله الآن هو أنه توجد عائلة من Boolean circuits
لجمع الأعداد الصحيحة غير السالبة معاً بحيث أن حجم الـ circuit رقم N، أي تلك التي تعمل
لمدخلات بطول N
هي big-O من N. الحجم الفعلي لـ CN
وفق تحليلنا كان 21 في N ناقص 11،
لكن ذلك big-O من N.
الآن ليس دائماً شيئاً ذكياً أن نتجاهل تفاصيل كهذه، لكن هنا هذا منطقي
لأنه يكشف الطبيعة الجوهرية لخوارزمية الجمع المعيارية، وهي أن تكلفتها تتزايد خطياً
بالنسبة لحجم الأعداد
التي نجمعها معاً، وهذا التعبير ليس حساساً لبعض التفاصيل
الدقيقة لنموذجنا،
مثل أي الـ gates بالضبط نعتبرها عمليات أولية.
مثلاً، إذا قررنا أن XOR gates يجب اعتبارها
عمليات أولية أو أن الـ FANOUT gates لا يجب
حسابها كـ gates أو كليهما،
سيظل لدينا أن جمع الأعداد الصحيحة يمكن حسابه بتكلفة big-O من N.
إليكم مثالاً آخر على
مسألة حسابية، ضرب الأعداد الصحيحة.
على غرار الجمع، يمكننا أن نسأل ما هي تكلفة
هذه العملية الحسابية.
إذا اعتبرنا خوارزمية الضرب
المعيارية، أي المقابل بالأساس الثنائي لطريقة ضرب الأعداد
التي تُدرَّس في المدارس الابتدائية،
والتي هي أساساً
إزاحة وجمع عندما نعمل مع أعداد بالثنائي، نجد أن هناك Boolean circuits بحجم big-O من N تربيع
لضرب أعداد صحيحة بـ N بت.
لن أمر على هذا بالتفصيل. بالطبع الـ circuits أكثر
تعقيداً قليلاً من تلك الخاصة بالجمع، لكن إذا فكرت في الطريقة
التي تعمل بها خوارزمية الضرب
المعيارية، فلا ينبغي أن يكون ذلك مفاجئاً.
في الجوهر، نحتاج
للقيام بحوالي N عملية جمع، كل منها بتكلفة خطية، وبالتالي ننتهي بتكلفة
تربيعية إجمالاً.
يمكن تعميم ذلك. إذا كان أحد العددين بـ N بت والآخر بـ M بت، فنحتاج circuits بحجم
big-O من N في M.
هنا، بالمناسبة، نستخدم فعلاً امتداداً لترميز big-O حيث لدينا متغيرات متعددة، لكن يمكن توسيعه هكذا،
وإذا كنت مهتماً
بالتفاصيل المحددة، سأحيلك إلى محتوى الكتاب
للدرس، والذي مرة أخرى مرتبط في
وصف الفيديو.
من الممكن فعلاً
ضرب عددين صحيحين بـ N بت بطريقة
أفضل بشكل تقاربي من خوارزمية الضرب المعيارية.
تحديداً، خوارزمية ضرب Schonhage-Strassen
تضرب عددين صحيحين بـ N بت بتكلفة big-O من
N في طول N
في طول طول N. فعندما تكبر N، كعشرات
الآلاف من البتات،
هذه فعلاً طريقة أكثر
كفاءة للضرب، لكنها معقدة والتكاليف الإضافية تجعلها غير عملية
للأعداد الأصغر.
فلنضف الضرب
إلى قائمة أمثلتنا.
ولأجل البساطة فقط، لنذكر التكلفة التي تعطيها خوارزمية الضرب المعيارية، وهي big-O من N تربيع.
فمرة أخرى، نركز على الطبيعة الجوهرية لهذه التكلفة، وهي أنها تتزايد بشكل تربيعي
أو دون تربيعي إذا استخدمنا طرقاً أفضل تقاربياً.
يمكننا أيضاً النظر في
مسألة قسمة الأعداد الصحيحة، المصاغة بدقة على الشاشة.
هنا نتحدث عن حساب حاصل القسمة والباقي، فالإجابة تتكون
من عددين صحيحين، Q و R.
مرة أخرى، هناك خوارزمية
معيارية للقسمة ولها أيضاً تكلفة
تربيعية ومثل الضرب،
هناك فعلاً خوارزميات
أفضل تقاربياً.
فكيف تقارن خوارزميات GCD؟
حسناً، خوارزمية Euclid تبين
أن تكلفتها تربيعية، وهذا ما كنت أقصده
في بداية الدرس عندما قلت أننا نستطيع حساب الـ GCD
بتكلفة تقريباً مماثلة لضرب عددين معاً.
مرة أخرى، هناك
خوارزميات أفضل تقاربياً على نفس المنوال مثل
الجمع والضرب،
رغم أن التكلفة أعلى
قليلاً في هذه الحالة، على الأقل بقدر ما نعلم.
سأذكر مثالاً آخر لمسألة لإضافتها إلى هذه القائمة، وهو الأُسّ المعياري.
هنا هناك ثلاثة أعداد
مدخلة، K و M و N، والهدف هو حساب
N أُس K معيارياً بالنسبة لـ M،
وهو يعني الباقي
بعد القسمة على M.
ليس واضحاً على الإطلاق، لكن يمكننا حساب الأُسّ
المعياري بتكلفة تكعيبية، أي big-O من N تكعيب
لأعداد صحيحة بـ N بت.
طريقة القيام بذلك ليست بحساب N أُس K أولاً ثم حساب الباقي.
حتى كتابة N أُس K قد تتطلب عدداً أُسّياً من البتات، لذا هذا النهج لن يعمل.
بدلاً من ذلك، يمكننا استخدام خوارزمية
تُسمى خوارزمية الأُسّ، والتي تُسمى أيضاً التربيع المتكرر حيث كل شيء يتم معيارياً بالنسبة لـ M
ونستخدم بتات K
للتربيع والضرب بشكل تكراري بطريقة
تجعل كل شيء يعمل.
فهذه أكثر تكلفة
من الأخريات، لكن يمكننا مع ذلك إجراء
الأُسّ المعياري بسرعة كبيرة على أعداد
بآلاف البتات.
فكيف تقارن تكاليف هذه المهام مع تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة؟
إذا بدأنا ببساطة وفكرنا
في القسمة التجريبية حيث نتحقق أولاً مما إذا كان 2 عاملاً للعدد المدخل
ثم نتحقق من 3 وهكذا، سننتهي بخوارزمية
مكلفة جداً، big-O من N تربيع في
2 أُس N على اثنين.
كل عملية قسمة تستغرق وقتاً تربيعياً وفي أسوأ الحالات، سنحتاج للبحث عن عوامل أولية حتى الجذر التربيعي للعدد المدخل،
ومن هنا يأتي N
على اثنين. إذا لم نجد عاملاً
أولياً عند تلك النقطة، يمكننا ببساطة التوقف لأن
العدد المدخل نفسه يجب أن يكون أولياً.
هذا مكلف للغاية لأن N تظهر كأُسّ في هذا التعبير، أي أن هذه
الخوارزمية ذات تكلفة أُسّية.
في المقابل، كل الأمثلة التي لدينا في هذا الصندوق هنا لها ما نسميه تكلفة كثيرة الحدود حيث يُرفع N إلى أُسّ،
لكن ذلك الأُسّ دائماً عدد ثابت لا ينمو مع
نمو طول المدخل.
في هذه الحالات، الأُسُس
هي واحد، واثنان، وثلاثة.
سأعود إلى مقارنة التكلفة كثيرة الحدود مقابل الأُسّية بعد لحظة، لكن أولاً، لننتهي مما
نعرفه عن التحليل.
ذكرت سابقاً
الغربال الحقلي العددي، وهو أفضل
خوارزمية تحليل لدينا من حيث كيفية تزايد تكلفتها.
في الواقع، تكلفة هذه الخوارزمية ليست مثبتة بدقة رياضياً لأنها مرتبطة ببعض الأسئلة المفتوحة في نظرية الأعداد،
لكن يُفترض أن تكلفتها
تبدو هكذا.
هذه المرة الـ big-O في الأُسّ، لكنني سأتجاوز
هذا التفصيل.
الاستنتاج الرئيسي هو أنها أفضل بشكل ملحوظ
من القسمة التجريبية لأنه رغم أن N تظهر
في الأُسّ،
إلا أنها مرفوعة إلى القوة 1/3 وهذا يترجم إلى تكلفة أقل بكثير ولهذا هذه الخوارزمية
تستطيع التعامل مع أعداد مثل RSA250، بينما القسمة التجريبية
بالتأكيد لا تستطيع.
لكنها لا تزال أُسّية بمعنى أن قوة من N تظهر في أُسّ، ونتيجة لذلك،
لا تزال لا تستطيع التعامل
مع أعداد مثل RSA1024.
الآن دعوني أقول المزيد قليلاً عن التكلفة كثيرة الحدود
مقابل التكلفة الأُسّية.
نقول أن خوارزمية لها
تكلفة كثيرة الحدود إذا كانت تكلفتها big-O من N أُس B،
حيث B يمكن أن يكون أي عدد موجب، لكن المفتاح هو أن B يجب أن يكون ثابتاً، أي أنه لا يتغير
مع نمو طول المدخل N.
للأمثلة التي رأيناها قبل قليل، أي جمع الأعداد الصحيحة، والضرب، والقسمة، وحساب الـ GCD
والأُسّ المعياري،
كانت B إما
واحد، أو اثنان، أو ثلاثة.
فكل هذه خوارزميات
ذات تكلفة كثيرة الحدود.
لكن عندما نقول تكلفة
كثيرة الحدود بشكل أعم، B يمكن أن يكون أي عدد موجب.
يمكن أن يكون حتى مليون،
لكنه يجب أن يكون ثابتاً.
كتجريد تقريبي جداً، الخوارزميات ذات التكلفة
كثيرة الحدود تُعتبر عادةً تمثل خوارزميات فعالة.
إنه بالتأكيد تبسيط مفرط، لكن كتوجيه تقريبي، يمكنك التفكير في خوارزمية
ذات تكلفة كثيرة الحدود
على أنها بطريقة ما
تستفيد من بنية المسألة لبناء حل بدلاً من نهج
القوة الغاشمة
أو البحث الشامل
عبر فضاء كبير جداً.
بالطبع، خوارزمية تكلفتها تتزايد بمقدار N أُس مليون
على مدخلات بطول N
لن تُعتبر بشكل معقول
فعالة، ولن نتوقع أن نتمكن من
تشغيلها على مدخلات كبيرة.
لكن مع ذلك حتى خوارزمية بـ N
أُس مليون يجب أن تفعل شيئاً ذكياً يعكس بطريقة ما بنية
أي مسألة تحلها لتجنب التزايد الأُسّي في التكلفة الذي سيرتبط بـ
بحث شامل عبر نطاق كبير.
وعملياً، تحديد خوارزمية ذات تكلفة كثيرة الحدود هو فعلاً مجرد خطوة
أولى نحو الكفاءة.
إذا كانت مسألة مهمة
واكتشف أحدهم أول خوارزمية ذات تكلفة
كثيرة الحدود لها، ربما بأُسّ كبير جداً،
يمكنك أن تكون واثقاً بشكل معقول أن مصممي الخوارزميات
سيجدون تحسينات تجعل ذلك الأُسّ ينخفض.
في الجوهر، يمكنك
التفكير في وجود خوارزمية ذات تكلفة
كثيرة الحدود لمسألة كإثبات جدوى
حل تلك المسألة
على مدخلات كبيرة بشكل معقول، لكن قد يتبقى الكثير من العمل للوصول إلى كفاءة حقيقية.
في نظرية التعقيد، من المعتاد القول أن تكلفة خوارزمية
تتزايد بشكل دون أُسّي إذا كانت التكلفة big-O من 2 أُس N
أُس إبسيلون لكل عدد حقيقي موجب إبسيلون، وإذا لم تكن دون أُسّية،
فهي أُسّية، أو قد تكون حتى فوق أُسّية مثل 2 أُس 2 أُس N،
وهي أُسّية مضاعفة،
لكن طالما أن المخرج
ليس بطول فوق أُسّي، كل مسألة يمكن فعلاً
حسابها بـ Boolean circuit
بتكلفة أُسّية كما اتضح. فالتمييز المهم هنا هو بين التكلفة كثيرة الحدود
والأُسّية.
لا نعرف أي خوارزميات كلاسيكية بتكلفة دون أُسّية لتحليل
الأعداد الصحيحة.
مثلاً، تكلفة الغربال الحقلي العددي ليست big-O من 2 أُس
N أُس إبسيلون عندما إبسيلون تساوي 1/3 أو أقل،
لذا فهي لا تحقق هذا التعريف.
إنها بلا شك خوارزمية ذكية جداً، لكنها لا تزال غربالاً ونحن لا نزال فعلياً نبحث
عبر فضاء كبير جداً لتحديد عوامل عدد معطى.
كما سنرى في الدرس القادم، هناك فعلاً خوارزمية كمية بتكلفة كثيرة
الحدود لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة.
خوارزمية Shor لها تكلفة كثيرة الحدود وتحديداً لها تكلفة تكعيبية، مشابهة للأُسّ المعياري.
فئة أخرى من المسائل قد
تكون على دراية بها هي فئة مسائل NP-complete.
لن أخوض في ما هي مسائل NP-complete في هذا الدرس، لكن يمكنك البحث عنها
إذا كنت مهتماً.
يُفترض أن
لا شيء من هذه المسائل له تكلفة دون أُسّية.
هذا أساساً نسخة قائمة على الـ circuits مما يُسمى أحياناً
فرضية الزمن الأُسّي، لكن حتى الآن لم يتمكن أحد
من معرفة كيفية إثباتها.
في الواقع، لا نستطيع حتى إثبات عدم وجود خوارزميات بتكلفة خطية لمسائل NP-complete.
الأمر صعب فعلاً، على
الأقل بقدر ما نعلم، لاستبعاد إمكانية
اكتشاف مستقبلي لخوارزمية
مبدعة بشكل لا يُصدق لهذه المسائل.
إليكم شكلاً يوضح
العلاقة بين التكلفة كثيرة الحدود والأُسّية.
على المحور X، لدينا طول المدخل لأي مسألة نفكر فيها، والمحور Y يمثل
تكلفة حل تلك المسألة
أو يمكنك التفكير
فيها على أنها الوقت المطلوب لحل المسألة إذا فضلت.
خوارزمية ذات تكلفة أُسّية
قد تتزايد هكذا.
للمدخلات القصيرة، قد لا تكون التكلفة مرتفعة بشكل خاص، مثل تحليل
العدد 12، مثلاً،
لكن كلما زاد طول المدخل، ستنفجر التكلفة في النهاية.
خوارزمية ذات تكلفة كثيرة الحدود،
من ناحية أخرى، قد يكون تزايدها هكذا.
التكلفة ستزداد عموماً كلما زادت المدخلات، وقد تكلف حتى أكثر من خوارزمية التكلفة الأُسّية
لبعض المدخلات،
لكنها في النهاية ستكون
أقل تكلفة بكثير من خوارزمية التكلفة الأُسّية ولا تنفجر
بنفس الطريقة المتطرفة
التي تفعلها خوارزميات التكلفة الأُسّية.
فإذا تخيلنا أن لدينا
حداً أقصى للتكلفة نحن مستعدون لإنفاقه، أو حداً أقصى للوقت الذي نحن مستعدون لانتظاره للحصول على إجابة،
إذا فضلت التفكير بالوقت، فإن خوارزمية التكلفة الأُسّية ستعمل فقط على مدخلات
حتى طول معين،
بينما بشكل عام، خوارزمية
التكلفة كثيرة الحدود ستسمح لنا بحل
المسألة لمدخلات أكبر.
ولهذا السبب، مثلاً، يمكننا بسهولة حساب الـ GCD لأعداد بآلاف
البتات، لكن في أسوأ الحالات،
لا نستطيع تحليل أعداد بهذا الحجم.
في الجزء الأخير من الدرس، سنوجه انتباهنا إلى تنفيذ العمليات الحسابية الكلاسيكية
على الحواسيب الكمية.
بشكل أدق، سنرى
أن أي عملية حسابية يمكن إجراؤها بواسطة Boolean circuit يمكن أيضاً إجراؤها بواسطة quantum circuit
بتكلفة مماثلة تقريباً. علاوة على ذلك، يمكن
القيام بذلك بطريقة نظيفة وهو أمر مهم إذا
أردنا تشغيل هذه العمليات الحسابية
كإجراءات فرعية داخل
عمليات حسابية كمية أكبر، وسأشرح ما أعنيه بنظيفة عندما نتعمق أكثر في النقاش.
سنستخدم Toffoli gates
في هذه العملية.
تذكروا أن Toffoli gates هي controlled-controlled-NOT gates، لذا تأثيرها على حالات الأساس المعياري
هو كما ترونه هنا على الشاشة.
لاحظوا أنه يمكننا أيضاً
التفكير في Toffoli gates على أنها مثل query gates
لدالة AND.
ليس المقصود أنها query gates بالمعنى الحرفي. كما ذكرت في بداية الدرس، نحن لا نعمل ضمن
نموذج الاستعلام في هذه المرحلة،
بل تأثيرها يتبع نفس النمط كـ query gate.
يمكننا التفكير في القيمتين الثنائيتين A و B كمدخلات لدالة AND ومثل query gate،
هذه القيم تُعاد
كجزء من المخرج وقيمة الدالة، أي AND المنطقي لـ A و B
يُضاف بـ XOR على الـ qubit السفلي. الآن، لم نضمّن Toffoli gates في مجموعة الـ gate المعيارية لدينا.
يمكننا تغيير رأينا إذا أردنا، لكننا لا نحتاج فعلاً
لذلك لأنه بدلاً من ذلك، يمكننا تنفيذ Toffoli
gates باستخدام Hadamard gates،
و T و T dagger gates
و controlled NOT gates كما ترون هنا.
ليس واضحاً على الإطلاق
أن هذه الـ circuit تنفذ Toffoli gate، لكنها تفعل، ويمكنك إما تصديق كلامي
أو ضرب كل شيء بنفسك لتحصل على تدريب إضافي، أو يمكنك ببساطة أن تطلب من Qiskit أو Python
أو أي برنامج يضرب المصفوفات أن يقوم بالضرب نيابةً عنك.
ويمكنك الاطلاع على
محتوى الكتاب للدرس لترى ذلك باستخدام Qiskit.
الآن يمكننا الانتقال إلى محاكاة Boolean gates بـ quantum circuits وكل ما سنحتاجه
لذلك هو NOT gates،
و controlled NOT gates و Toffoli gates.
هذه العمليات كلها حتمية بالإضافة إلى كونها وحدوية وأحياناً نصف
عمليات كهذه بأنها عكوسة، وفي الواقع،
دراسة الحوسبة العكوسة سبقت الحوسبة الكمية ومن هنا يأتي هذا
الإجراء بأكمله فعلاً.
الـ Boolean gates التي نحتاج
للقلق بشأنها هي NOT gates و AND gates و FANOUT gates،
وما سنبينه هو أنه يمكننا تنفيذ هذه الـ gates، أو محاكاتها إذا
فضلت، باستخدام NOT gates،
و controlled NOT gates و Toffoli gates.
لأكون واضحاً، ما نريده
هو quantum circuits تسمح لنا بحساب قيم الـ Boolean gates التي ذكرتها للتو
عندما نعطيها qubits في
حالات الأساس المعياري كمدخلات.
لمدخلات حالة كمية عشوائية، سيتحدد التأثير
بالخطية كالمعتاد.
لا نحتاج لفعل أي شيء
خاص مع الـ NOT gates. الـ NOT gates هي NOT gates ويمكن تنفيذها مباشرة.
والـ OR gates يمكن محاكاتها
باستخدام Toffoli و NOT gates.
الـ AND gates سهلة، خاصةً في ضوء ما قلته قبل لحظات عن أن Toffoli gates هي أساساً
تنفيذات query gate
لدالة AND.
لنكون دقيقين، ما يمكننا فعله هو إدخال qubit جديد مُهيأ في حالة الصفر
ونجعل ذلك الـ qubit هو الهدف
لـ Toffoli gate ونجعل qubitي الإدخال
يكونان عناصر التحكم.
تُعطى أسماء مختلفة
لـ qubits إضافية كهذه، والتي غالباً ما تُدخل
في العمليات الحسابية الكمية وسأسميها qubits
مساحة العمل فقط لاختيار اسم.
افتراضنا المعتاد حول qubits مساحة العمل هو أنها تبدأ في حالة الصفر ويمكننا غالباً إعادتها
إلى حالة الصفر
عندما ننتهي منها، لكن ليس دائماً.
في الرسم لدينا ket صفر داخل المستطيل المنقط للإشارة إلى أن
تهيئة هذا الـ qubit
هي جزء من العملية، وإذا لم يكن لديك
qubit جديد كهذا، لن تتمكن
من القيام بهذه المحاكاة.
الـ qubit السفلي للإخراج
هو ما يهمنا لأنه نتيجة
عملية AND ونكون قد انتهينا أساساً
من الاثنين الآخرين
لذا يمكنهما البقاء داخل الصندوق.
في الواقع، يمكنك حتى تخيل أن التخلص من هذين الـ qubitين هو جزء من مهمة
محاكاة هذه الـ AND gate،
نوعاً ما مثل نفايات
يجب تنظيفها.
لكن على أي حال، هكذا يمكننا
محاكاة AND gate.
الآن بعد أن عرفنا كيف نعمل AND gates، يمكننا عمل OR gates باستخدام
أحد قوانين De Morgan.
إذا وضعت NOT gates على المدخلين والمخرج لـ AND
gate، ستحصل على OR gate، فالأمر بهذه البساطة.
وآخرها FANOUT، ولهذه كل ما نحتاجه
هو controlled NOT gate مع qubit مساحة عمل.
تحديداً، إذا
جعلنا qubit مساحة العمل هو الهدف، فإننا فعلياً ننسخ أي حالة أساس معياري تأتي،
فذلك يعمل كـ FANOUT gate.
إذاً لدينا جميع الـ gates.
والآن بعد أن لدينا جميع الـ gates، يمكننا الانتقال إلى الـ circuits.
لنفترض أن لدينا
Boolean circuit اسمها C، ويمكن أن تكون أي
Boolean circuit تختارها
طالما أنها مكونة من
AND أو NOT و FANOUT gates.
سنجعل T هو عدد الـ gates في C وسنسمي الدالة التي تحسبها C بالاسم F.
فيمكننا التفكير في F على أنها بالشكل الذي ترونه هنا، حيث N هو عدد بتات الإدخال لـ C،
M هو عدد بتات الإخراج وسيغما هي الأبجدية الثنائية.
وما نفعله هو ببساطة المرور واحدة تلو الأخرى على gates الخاصة بـ C.
نترك الـ NOT gates كما هي ونستبدل الأخريات بالمحاكاة
التي وصفتها للتو.
فإذا كانت C تبدو هكذا، فما نحصل عليه هو circuit
R تبدو هكذا.
في هذا الرسم، جميع
qubits مساحة العمل التي نحتاجها للمحاكاة تم سحبها من صناديقها وجمعها في الأسفل.
إذاً K هو العدد الإجمالي لـ
qubits مساحة العمل التي نحتاجها، وهو واحد لكل gate من gates الخاصة بـ C ما عدا الـ NOT gates.
لمخرج R، لدينا الـ qubits التي تقابل
مخرج C، وهنا تلك الـ qubits
موضحة في الأعلى،
رغم أنه لا يهم فعلاً في نهاية كل هذا
ما إذا كانت في الأعلى أم لا.
لنكون دقيقين، بافتراض أننا شغّلنا R على حالة أساس معياري تقابل
سلسلة N-بت عشوائية X،
هذه الـ M qubits للإخراج ستكون في حالة الأساس المعياري
المقابلة لـ F من X.
لدينا أيضاً جميع الـ qubits المتبقية من الـ AND و OR gates.
لا يزال علينا حسابها، وإذا جمعناها كلها معاً، ستكون في حالة أساس معياري ما.
مهما كانت حالة الأساس المعياري فهي يجب أن تكون دالة ما للسلسلة X، وسنسمي
تلك الدالة G.
إذاً G هي دالة جديدة
تحددها gates الخاصة بـ C وتخبرنا بالحالة
التي تكون فيها هذه الـ qubits المتبقية
بعد تشغيل R. G هو الحرف التالي بعد F، فهذا سبب
لتسمية هذه الدالة G،
لكن سبب آخر لتسميتها G هو أن G اختصار لـ garbage أي نفايات.
هذه كلها qubits نفايات، وبالتحديد لدينا
qubitا نفايات لكل AND gate ولكل OR gate.
العدد الإجمالي للـ gates
التي نحتاجها هو big-O من T.
ذلك لأنه لكل gate من gates الخاصة بـ C، نحتاج عدداً محدوداً من quantum gates.
الـ OR gate هي الأكثر تكلفة. لها نحتاج ثلاث NOT gates بالإضافة إلى Toffoli gate واحدة،
و Toffoli gate تكلفنا 15 gate من مجموعة الـ gate المعيارية.
فهذا يعني بحد أقصى 18 gate
في R لكل gate من gates الخاصة بـ C.
إذا أردت تحسين هذا، يمكنك ذلك، لكن لأغراض
تحليل تقاربي تقريبي، يمكننا ببساطة القول أن
R بها big-O من T gates.
إذاً تمكنا من
حساب نفس الدالة F التي حسبتها الـ Boolean
circuit الأصلية C،
وفعلنا ذلك بتكلفة خطية في حجم C.
إذا كان كل ما يهمنا هو
حساب هذه الدالة F، فقد انتهينا.
لكن للأسف، لدينا
qubits النفايات هذه وqubits النفايات هذه
ستدمر عموماً
أنماط التداخل التي تجعل الخوارزميات الكمية تعمل إذا حاولنا استخدام
هذه الـ circuit R كإجراء فرعي
داخل خوارزمية كمية أكبر.
لكن يمكننا فعلاً التخلص
من هذه النفايات، والطريقة التي يمكننا بها
ذلك هي الاستفادة من أن الـ circuit R يمكن عكسها،
أو بعبارة أخرى، يمكننا
تشغيلها بالعكس.
لتوضيح كيف يعمل هذا، لنتخيل أننا نشغل R أولاً ثم نشغل R بالعكس،
وهو ما يمكننا التعبير عنه بـ R dagger.
لأكون واضحاً بشأن هذا، ما يعنيه هو أننا نطبق gates
الخاصة بـ R بالترتيب المعاكس ونأخذ معكوس
كل gate.
الـ NOT gates و controlled NOT
gates و Toffoli gates هي فعلاً معكوسات نفسها، لذا إذا كنا نفكر
بهذه الـ gates،
فإن R dagger هي فعلاً R مع الـ gates مطبقة
بالترتيب المعاكس.
لكن بشكل عام، يمكننا دائماً تشغيل أي quantum circuit وحدوية بالعكس بالطريقة التي وصفتها للتو،
أي أننا نطبق الـ gates
بالترتيب المعاكس ونستبدل كل
gate فردية بمعكوسها.
إذا فعلنا ذلك، سنجد أن تشغيل R أولاً ثم تشغيل R بالعكس
لا يفعل شيئاً على الإطلاق.
فإذا بدأنا في حالة أساس معياري كما لدينا هنا، فسننتهي بنفس حالة الأساس المعياري بالضبط.
بالطبع، فعل ذلك فقط
ليس مفيداً جداً، لكن ما يمكننا فعله هو إدخال مجموعة من الـ qubits الإضافية وتحديداً،
هي M qubits حيث M هو عدد بتات الإخراج للـ circuit C.
هذه الـ qubits الإضافية يمكن
أن تكون في أي حالة كمية، لكن لشرح كيف يعمل هذا، سنفترض أنها في حالة أساس معياري
تقابل سلسلة ما Y. إذاً Y سلسلة من M بت، وما يمكننا فعله هو تنفيذ
مجموعة من controlled NOT
gates كما ترون هنا، والتي تضيف فعلياً بـ XOR السلسلة F من X
على السلسلة Y المخزنة
في هذه الـ M qubits السفلية.
وبالتالي مخرج
العملية الحسابية بأكملها هو كما يظهر على الشاشة.
X و Y سلاسل ثنائية عشوائية. X بها N بت و Y بها M بت، ونحتاج أيضاً K qubit مساحة عمل.
عندما نشغل R، نحسب F من X وتُخزن تلك السلسلة
في الـ M qubits العليا، لكن لدينا أيضاً
مجموعة من qubits النفايات،
فنضيف بـ XOR المخرج F من
X على الـ M qubits السفلية ثم نشغل R بالعكس
لتنظيف النفايات.
يجب أن أشير إلى أنه من المهم أن R حتمية.
إذا كانت هذه الـ M qubits العليا يمكن أن تكون بدلاً من ذلك في تراكب ما
من حالات الأساس المعياري، هذا لن يعمل بشكل صحيح،
لكن هذا يعمل عندما
تكون R حتمية.
فإذا قارنا الـ quantum
circuit التي بنيناها للتو بالـ Boolean circuit الأصلية C، نرى أنها أساساً
تعمل بنفس الطريقة
التي تعمل بها query gate
لدالة عشوائية.
هناك فرق هنا، وهو أننا نحتاج
qubits مساحة العمل هذه لجعل كل شيء يعمل، لكن خلاف ذلك قد
بنينا فعلياً query gate
أو query circuit لأي دالة تحسبها C.
تمكنا أيضاً، بالمناسبة، من إعادة qubits مساحة
العمل إلى حالتها الأولية، لذا يمكن من حيث المبدأ إعادة استخدامها
كـ qubits مساحة عمل لعمليات
حسابية لاحقة.
إذا أردنا، يمكننا وضع صندوق حول الـ quantum circuit بأكملها وتسميتها Q والعلاقة بـ
C تصبح أوضح.
الـ circuit Q ستكون
أكبر من C بشكل عام. نحتاج حفنة من quantum
gates في Q لكل gate من gates الخاصة بـ C،
ونحتاج أيضاً controlled
NOT gates في المنتصف، لكن العدد لا يزال
خطياً في حجم C.
يجب أيضاً ملاحظة أن هذا إجراء عام تماماً يعمل لأي Boolean circuit، ولم نحاول على الإطلاق تحسين Q.
لـ circuit محددة C، قد تكون هناك فعلاً
طرق لتقليل حجم Q، وذلك يشمل استخدام طرق
تقلل عدد qubits
مساحة العمل المطلوبة في حال كان ذلك شيئاً
نريد فعله، وهذا هو الإجراء لتشغيل
العمليات الحسابية الكلاسيكية
على حاسوب كمي.
إنه بسيط جداً، لكنه شيء مهم
أن نكون قادرين على فعله.
بالتحديد، الآن بعد أن
عرفنا كيف نفعل ذلك، نحن أحرار في استخدام أي عمليات حسابية كلاسيكية نريد
داخل العمليات الحسابية الكمية، بشرط أن نتبع هذا الشكل حيث يتم إعادة المدخل ويُضاف المخرج بـ XOR
على مجموعة من الـ qubits
تماماً كما كان لدينا مع query gates.
التكلفة تتزايد خطياً. فمثلاً، يمكننا
إنشاء quantum circuits لمسائل مثل جمع الأعداد الصحيحة،
والضرب، والقسمة، وحساب الـ GCD والأُسّ المعياري، وكل هذا يمكن إنجازه بنفس التكلفة التقاربية
كما هو الحال مع Boolean circuits.
نحتاج qubits مساحة عمل للقيام بذلك، لكنها على الأقل متاحة لإعادة الاستخدام مرة أخرى عندما
ننتهي منها.
ملاحظة أخيرة تستحق الذكر هي أن هذه الطريقة توفر لنا طريقة لتنفيذ query gates،
والتي أشرت إليها في الدرس السابق.
أي أنه إذا كانت لدينا خوارزمية استعلام تأخذ دالة F كمدخل، ولدينا طريقة لحساب
F بـ Boolean circuit،
فيمكننا اتباع هذا الإجراء لبناء query gate لتلك الدالة ثم تشغيل خوارزمية الاستعلام عليها.
ما إذا كان ذلك شيئاً مفيداً يعتمد على مسألة الاستعلام نفسها وما نحاول تحقيقه، لكن في الجوهر، هذا
البناء يوفر لنا
طريقة لربط نموذج الاستعلام بنموذج حوسبي أكثر معيارية.
هذا بمعنى ما هو كيف تعمل خوارزمية Shor لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة.
سنبني quantum circuits
كهذه من بعض العمليات الحسابية التي تحدثنا عنها سابقاً في الدرس.
وبفعل ذلك، نعطي
الـ quantum circuits القدرة على تقييم تلك العمليات على تراكبات من الحالات الكلاسيكية.
وكما سنرى، ذلك يسمح لنا بتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة بكفاءة.
هذه نهاية هذا الدرس، الذي ركز بشكل رئيسي على تأسيس قاعدة
للخوارزميات الكمية في إطار حوسبي معياري
غير صندوق أسود.
تحدثنا عن التكلفة الحسابية بشكل رئيسي من خلال عدسة المسائل المرتبطة بنظرية الأعداد الأساسية.
ناقشنا التكلفة كثيرة الحدود
مقابل الأُسّية للمهام الحسابية، ورأينا كيف أن العمليات الحسابية الكلاسيكية
يمكن تنفيذها بواسطة quantum circuits بطريقة نظيفة خالية من النفايات تسمح باستخدامها كإجراءات فرعية
داخل عمليات حسابية كمية أكبر.
أتمنى أن تنضموا إلي في الدرس القادم حيث سنرى كيف تستخدم خوارزمية Shor هذه الأفكار، مما يسمح لنا بتحليل
الأعداد الصحيحة بتكلفة كثيرة الحدود.
وداعاً حتى ذلك الحين.